[MUSIC PLAYING]
SISSIE HSIAO: Hello, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, hi.
Nice applause right
before I even get started.
So good morning.
It's great to be here at
I/O. I'm Sissie Hsiao,
and I lead Google's mobile app
advertising products at Google.
And this talk will be about
building a successful app
business with ads.
So first off, it's
just incredible
to hear all of the
wonderful things
that you're building
in your mobile apps.
And one of my favorite
apps is the one
that you see on the screen.
It's called Calm, and
it's a relaxation app.
And I first sought this
app out because I certainly
needed more calm in my life.
And so for many of
us, apps like Calm
are the very reason
that we find our phones
to be so indispensable.
Now, for developers
like all of you,
mobile has democratized
access to billions
of users like me and you.
And according to App Annie,
in 2017 over $86 billion
will be transacted
in apps alone.
And this is just
the digital goods.
This does not include real
world goods and services that
are transacted through apps.
So there is an incredible
opportunity for all of you
to build great services to reach
and touch consumers' lives.
Now, at the same
time, because there's
an incredible opportunity,
there's incredible competition.
There are millions of free apps
vying for users' attention.
So you need to make sure that
your app and your advertising
dollars help your app
stand above the crowd.
On the flip side, if you're
using in-app ads monetization,
well, guess what?
Users' expectation
for user experiences
continues to get
higher and higher,
because they have so
many wonderful choices.
So if you're putting
ads into your app,
you need to make sure
that those are really
great and elegant
experiences for users.
Or another way to say it,
both the app and the ads
have to be really,
really seamlessly done.
And this is where
we want to help.
We want to help you solve
two fundamental problems
to building a great,
successful app business.
Number one is, how do
you grow your user base?
How do you find the right
users, the profitable users,
that will resonate
with your service
and get excited and subscribe
or pay for the services
that you're building?
And number two, how do you
monetize your apps more
effectively with in-app
ads monetization?
This is what I'm
here to talk about.
We want to help you build
the tools so that you
can focus on building
amazing apps and the content
for your users.
So let's start with
number one, which
is how do you find those most
valuable users, the ones that
will like your app?
Now, the good news for all of
you is that billions of users
are downloading
billions of apps.
Last year alone, Google Play
saw 94 billion app downloads
happen.
And I've been watching
this year over year.
This number continues to grow.
It's just incredible.
But the really hard thing
about finding the right user
is that there is no typical
profile for a user anymore.
Let me explain what I mean.
Let's take the very
popular vertical of games.
Now, contrary to what
many people still believe,
mobile gamers are
not just young males.
And in fact, men and women play
mobile games about equally.
And furthermore, in the US,
females from the age of 10
all the way to 65, about
65% of that population,
this huge range of females,
plays mobile games.
One of my favorite
things to do is
to share my favorite
mobile games
with my daughter, who's seven.
So apps are really
transcending boundaries
and defying our presumptions
of what users really like.
And this is what makes
app promotion really hard.
You're fishing for
the right users
who want to use your services.
So to help make user acquisition
easier and more effective
for you, we built a product
called Universal App
Campaigns, or UAC.
Now, what is UAC?
Very simply, it's
an ads product,
and it helps you find the
right user for your app
across multiple billion
user surfaces, including
Google Search, the Google
Play Store, YouTube,
and over three million sites and
apps across the Google Display
Network.
But before we talk a lot
more about what UAC does
and how it works, let me share
a few stories about developers
who are using UAC to accomplish
their business goals.
Let me start with Kabam.
Now, many of you might
know about Kabam.
They're an award winning game
developer in San Francisco.
And they have some
really amazing titles,
like Marvel's
Contests of Champions
and The Fast and the Furious.
And Kabam came to us with a
problem for their business.
They wanted to grow their global
daily active users for the game
Marvel's Contest of Champions.
Let's hear a little bit more
from them about their story.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Kabam is a world leader of
massive multiplayer mobile
games.
Marvel Contest of Champions
is an action fighting game
that released in 2014,
and users can play
with anyone else in the world.
Because Marvel is
a very social game,
it's important that we find
players all over the globe.
Our target audience are engaged
daily active users, or what we
like to call them are regulars.
These regulars are hard to
find, because they're not bound
by geography, gender, or age.
We really didn't
have the resources
to process and analyze
millions of data points
to find our target gamer.
From Hong Kong to
Dallas, each player
has their own unique
gamer profile.
At the end of the
day, we just want
to reach more people
in the world who
are going to become regulars.
We worked with the
Google account team
to create a bit
strategy that would
find the regulars who would want
to play Contest of Champions.
Google's automation helped us
find a huge untapped audience
that we didn't know existed.
Considering our game is three
years old with a high user
base, that really isn't
an easy thing to do.
We reached hundreds of
thousands of new players.
Year over year install
volume increased
by two and a half times,
with our target return on ad
spend increasing by 70%.
Now we've been able to focus
on our overall growth strategy
rather than worrying about
manually optimizing campaigns.
[END PLAYBACK]
SISSIE HSIAO: It's
been really incredible
for us to be part of
Kabam's success story.
And we're glad that despite
Marvel's Contest of Champions
being a game that's
been out since 2014
and already having
millions of users
that we were able to help
them grow their installs
by 6x quarter over quarter.
And maybe more
importantly, their ROAS,
or Return On Ad Spend,
increased by 70%.
So let's look at another
example, this time in Europe.
Now, mytaxi is Europe's
leading taxi app,
and it really helps consumers
book and find taxi rides.
Now, you can imagine that
this on demand ride business
is very competitive.
It certainly is
competitive in the US,
and it's competitive
in Europe as well.
So their main business challenge
that they came to us with was,
how can I find more
users for my taxi app
that will actually take rides,
and after that first ride,
continue to take more rides?
They just wanted those
people to have the frequency
of use of their service.
So in September, they
came to us and tried
UAC for their expansion
into 11 markets in Germany.
And within just a
few months, they
were able to increase their
installs in these 11 test
markets by 70%.
And more importantly, they've
tripled their growth rate
of finding those first
time riders, riders
who are new to their service.
So we're also incredibly
happy that mytaxi
was able to use our tools
to build their business.
Now, you might
wonder, how is UAC
able to deliver
these performance
characteristics for two
very different businesses?
One is a game expanding
a mature business.
One is conquesting into a
new region for a taxi app.
Well, the secret sauce is
not really that secret.
It's machine learning.
And UAC uses machine
learning to learn
which app users are the
most relevant and right
for your app.
And it does this by
combining, in real time,
hundreds of millions
of signal combinations
to understand where
the ad should show,
who the ad should show to,
what the ad should look like,
and also what to
pay for that ad.
And it's doing all of this
optimization in real time
to optimize the
value of your dollars
so that we return the highest
ROI for your advertising
budgets.
And this helps you to
save both time and money
for your acquisition campaigns.
Because of this,
I'm also incredibly
proud to say that we
have now delivered
over 10 billion installs
for developers like you
through our ad services.
And potentially
even more important,
we're delivering
over seven billion
in app events per quarter.
What are in-app events?
These are the events
that matter to your app,
whether it's subscribing
to the service
or passing a level in a game
or taking a ride in your ride
sharing app.
But this is not enough.
I'd like to share some new
announcements on what we're
adding to universal campaigns.
The first thing is we know that
a really good way for users
to understand what
your app is about
is to show them a
video of the app.
And this is why
earlier this year, we
introduced a new feature,
a click-to-play video
ad in Google Play.
Now, this unit is
exactly like it says.
Users go to the Google Play
store looking for some app
to download.
They're invited to watch a video
about an app they might like.
And after watching
that video, they
can decide whether they want
to download the app or not.
This leads to very qualified
users for that advertiser.
Sorry.
Now, another way to
qualify high value users
is to actually let them try
the app before they install it.
And I'm sure many
of you have heard
of this new technology called
Google Play Instant, which
is really cool.
Basically, if you haven't
heard about this technology,
it allows you to build a
small version of your game
and have it load instantly
for consumers to try.
Now, how does this work with
Universal App Campaigns?
Very simply.
We are going to show users
a Try Now button in the app
install ads that they encounter.
So if you're using
Google Play Instant,
you plug it into
Universal App Campaigns,
and now users get a
try now experience
where they get to
experience, potentially,
a level of your game before
deciding to download.
And this is something we're
actively experimenting with
and will launch in
the coming months.
However, making ads informative
and engaging isn't enough.
We also want to make them
super relevant for users.
About 70% of users say that
they download an app based on
whether they think they're
going to use it or not,
which seems pretty
intuitive to me.
And so to help provide
more information
about your app in
your install ads,
we're introducing a new
feature, the ability
to surface in-app content in
your Universal App Campaigns
ads.
Now, maybe an example is
more clear on explaining
how this works.
So let's look at the app Wish.
For those of you who
don't have the Wish app,
Wish is a retail app.
And they sell a lot
of different things.
They sell kid stuff, they
sell sports equipment,
they sell travel
stuff, they sell a lot
of different lines of products.
And so what Wish
can do now is they
can feed that list of
products to AdWords.
And after they've connected
that to Universal App Campaigns,
we will now use machine
learning to figure out
which products to service
to which users before they
download the app.
So for example, some users might
want to be buying kid's stuff,
because they're parents.
This is something that the
machine learning algorithm
will optimize towards.
Or another set of users might be
interested in sports equipment.
That's what they'll
optimize towards.
So this is just
another way for us
to surface more information
about what your app is
for your potential users.
Now let's switch gears
and talk about something
really important, which is
the measurement of your app
install ads.
I know a lot of you
care about understanding
the ROI and efficiency
of those ads dollars
that you're putting forth.
So we're announcing
a new metric called
View Through Conversions,
or VTCs, for Universal App
Campaigns.
Very simply, this metric just
correlates your impressions
on video and display
ads to the app installs
that happen downstream.
And this is something that
will surface in AdWords
in the coming months.
Now, developers like InnoGames,
which created Forge of Empires,
have been using
VTCs to understand
how effective their
Universal App Campaigns are.
And this is also a great way
to compare VTCs between Google
and other acquisition channels.
Now, the other thing I'd
like to add about VTCs
is that they will be surfaced
in both AdWords and our app
attribution partners, because
we know that many of you
are using those surfaces
to compare metrics
between different providers.
So we're really excited
about the huge opportunity
that you have to
build a great service
and get that service into the
hands of billions of users.
And my team is
excited to continue
working on Universal
App Campaigns
to help you achieve your
user acquisition goals.
And now, the flip side
of building a successful
apps business, which
is monetization.
I'd like to share
with you how Google
is helping you build great
monetization into your app
through advertising.
Now, getting ads into
your app may seem easy,
but it's actually not that
obvious, and here's why.
Number one is what I
talked about earlier.
Users have a really high
expectation for the apps
that they use.
So if you're putting
ads in, they better
be working really well.
And number two is
fine, I'm opted
in to showing ads to users.
How exactly do I make the
most from my ad partners?
How do I maximize revenue?
Those are the two problems
that we want to help you with.
Let's start with
great ads experiences.
Now, stepping back
for a second, I've
been working on apps
for six, seven years,
and I've been really,
really interested
with the emergence of
so many different ways
that users can pay for things.
They can pay through
subscriptions.
in-app purchases.
They can pay through
virtual currencies.
And now there's other
things like tipping.
There's just so
many different ways
that monetization is
emerging in the apps surface.
And one thing that we've
seen become very popular
recently is hybrid
monetization, which
is just a fancy way of
saying in-app purchases
and ads in the same app.
And when app developers
are doing this,
one thing that's become
very popular recently
is something called
rewarded ads.
For those of you who don't
know what rewarded ads are,
very simply, users opt
into watching an ad,
and in return, they get
a service in the app.
Now, this is very,
very popular in games,
but I'll share a non-game
example, Pandora.
Pandora realized
that many users who
were using their
music service were not
going to become subscribers.
So instead they offered
those users a choice.
Would you like to watch
an ad and in return get
some ad free listening?
And by and large, this is
an incredibly great model,
because Pandora gets to monetize
those users who are not paying,
and the user gets a service,
they're happy with it,
and the advertiser actually gets
a very engaged and qualified
view from that user.
So let's take a look at a
second example, Avid.ly,
which is a creator of a
game called Bingo Party.
Now, Avid.ly was very concerned
about adding ads to their app.
They were worried
that ads were going
to ruin the gameplay
experience, that users
would flee to other free games.
So they decided to
try rewarded ads,
just to see how it would work.
And the surprising results are,
number one, they made more.
They got an increase in revenue
between IAP and ads by 40%.
But in addition,
session duration
grew by 20%, which means that
by adding these ads to the game,
users actually paid
more and played longer.
So everybody wins, right?
Avid.ly, Pandora are
showcasing that when
you put the ads into the app
in an elegant way, users,
publishers, advertisers
are all going to win.
And because this model
has become very popular,
it's no surprise that we have
seen rewarded ads in AdMob
grow by 9x since we introduced
it in March of last year.
And we've added a lot more
to rewarded ads since then.
One of the things
that we've added
is rewarded with
multiple options.
And that's what you see
on this screen here.
Essentially, users are
deciding to watch an ad
to get some item or
service in the app.
Why don't you let them pick
which ad they want to watch?
This leads, again, to the
user being more interested
in the ad that they've
decided to watch,
and also the advertisers getting
a much more qualified user.
This also then leads to higher
CPMs for you as a developer.
Now, one of the new things
I'd like to share today,
I'm really excited about, is
rewarded reporting in AdMob.
Now, this may not sound like,
wow, what's going on here?
Reported reporting
is super important,
because you need to know
how rewarded actually
works in your app.
So here we're going to
share a lot more metrics
about exactly what's going
on with the users that
are interacting with
your rewarded ads, which
rewarded ads are working and
not, what reward units are more
resonating with users, what
are the view through rates
of reward ads.
And this lets you
as a developer tune
and optimize how and where you
offer these rewards and also
what reward to provide to users.
This also gives you a
sense of how it's affecting
your core user experience.
Is it additive, like the
case we saw with Avid.ly?
And how is it
affecting your RPU?
So this is going to be
available in AdMob very soon.
Now, I just talked about
great ads experiences in apps.
Let me talk about something
else which is really important,
which is maximizing
the revenue that you're
getting from your ad partners.
So typically the
way this works today
is something called mediation.
And very simply,
this is the ordering
of how you sell your ads
to different ad partners.
Now, mediation traditionally
works on a historical pricing
basis, which basically means,
in this mock up you see here,
Network A paid $2 in the
past, so they're at the top.
And Network B and
Network C are below that,
because historically
their prices were lower.
Now, the flaw with this
model, as you can see,
is that at any given
moment, each impression
can be priced differently.
And in fact,
Network B or C might
have a higher price
for an impression
than Network A at any time.
So we think we can help.
Earlier this year, we announced
a feature called Open Bidding.
Now, what Open Bidding does is
it takes mediation and instead
moves it to a real time
bidded auction system.
What does that mean?
Very simply, every impression is
available for every ad network
to bid into simultaneously
and in real time.
And this means a
higher and better price
for each and every
impression for those of you
who are selling ads
inventory in your apps.
Now, the benefits are
beyond pricing as well.
Mediation typically requires
integration of multiple ad
network SDKs, as well as
launching multiple surfaces
to reconcile billing and
figuring out payments.
With Open Bidding, we're
trying to resolve all that.
You can get most of the
[INAUDIBLE] benefits from all
of those ad providers
through a single AdMob SDK,
leading to a lighter app
for your users to download,
and also less development time.
And what's more,
AdMob will often
manage the billing to
and provide transparency
into your metrics.
So you don't have to
chase down payments or log
into multiple interfaces.
Now, developers like Ilyon here
are seeing remarkable results
by being part of our
Open Bidding beta.
And this is something that
we're going to continue
expanding over time.
In fact, in addition
to the partners
that we launched
earlier this year,
we have now added the
global ad network InMobi
to our Open Bidding feature.
Now, let's talk about a second
way for maximizing revenue
from your ad partners, something
called open measurement.
And very, very simply,
brand advertisers
are often buying
impressions for users,
and they want to make sure that
those impressions are seen.
Hence the viewability part.
Now, in reality, in
the past, if developers
wanted to guarantee
viewability of their ads,
they had to integrate
multiple SDKs that
yielded disparate numbers
of their viewability.
So to solve that,
what we've done
is joined an IAB
led coalition, which
is unifying and simplifying
down to a single methodology
for measuring
viewability in your ads.
So we're excited to announce
that we have integrated the IAB
Open Measurement SDK into
our Google Mobile Ads GMA
and our Interactive
Media Ads IMA SDKs.
So this solution will help you
save time as well as reflect
the true value of
your app inventory.
Now in addition, our
developers on DoubleClick,
both our DFP and our
ad exchange products,
will also be able
to use this beta.
So thank you so much.
We've covered a ton today.
So if you have any questions
about both user acquisition
and Universal App Campaigns
or our AdMob announcements,
please come to our office hours.
So I'd just like
to close by saying,
it is an incredible
time to be a developer.
You can build great services
to reach billions of users,
and our job is to help you build
a great business foundation
on top of those services.
We want to help you
with two problems.
User acquisition, finding
the right uses for your app.
And number two, in-app
ads monetization.
Continue to make more
and maximize your revenue
from the ads that you're
adding to your app.
Thank you so much
for all of your time,
and enjoy the rest
of your time at I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]